Speaker 1: So listen, I am not like
a big Neil Cavuto fan. Neil Cavuto
has been a Fox News host for a really long time,
maybe since the start of the network he's
been. He's been there for a very long time.
I often disagree with him on politics. Neil Cavuto
is immunocompromised. He has multiple sclerosis.
He has had heart surgery. He is vaccinated. And
Neil Cavuto on Fox News is saying Get vaccinated.
He's begging. He's saying the political stuff
around this. It's got to stop, go and get
vaccinated. He's begging people to get vaccinated,
and he's being ignored by his entire network of
evening hosts, including Tucker Carlson and Laura
Ingraham, the Fox and Friends people. It's like
he's shouting into a void. Here he is. I mean,
I'll just play the clip and it's you. This is it's
a lone voice on Fox News. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 2: I feel very strongly, and I know we
live in this hyper politicized age that
people get vaccinated. I know, you know,
a lot of people say that's a private
decision. I get that. I appreciate that.
But I'd like to urge people of all sorts.
Please get vaccinated. Yeah, he's saying
Speaker 1: it's a private decision. And
the decision that would make most sense
for you to make is to go and get
vaccinated, which is perfectly reasonable
and in line with this freedom ideology.
Speaker 2: So this situation for me,
being immunocompromised, half the cases
we're hearing on the breakthrough front
are among the immunocompromised people.
Speaker 1: I should mention the context is
also that Neil Cavuto. Contracted COVID, and he
believes he had a relatively mild case despite
being immunocompromised because he's vaccinated
Speaker 2: like me, who've had, you know,
and have multiple sclerosis or prior heart
situation or cancer. There are many like that
all around it. So the mind is not a secret at Fox,
but there are plenty of people working around you,
Howie and Fox, and all types of business
environments. Wow are susceptible to this
sort of thing. You can help them out a lot
if, whatever your views on Band-Aids and I
get that no one likes to be ordered to. But in
the end, if you can get vaccinated and think of
somebody else and think of what that could
mean to them and their survivability from
something like this, we'll all be better off.
Speaker 1: This is eminently reasonable. Who can
disagree with any word of
what Neil Cavuto is saying?
But the context is Fox News, and he's screaming
into a void. Here's one more clip. And he's
saying Toss the politics around this, please.
Speaker 2: Lost five million globally to this.
We've lost nearly 800000 in the US. Take
the political speaking points and toss them.
For now, I'm begging you, toss them and think
of what's good not only for yourself, but for
those around you. If you don't want to do it for
yourself, if you think it's a pain in the ass,
I get that right. But think of others around
you. I daresay people who experience this sort
seen loved ones who've been affected by this
or have never died from this are not judging
the wisdom of mandates. They're wishing
they got vaccinated and they did it right.
Speaker 1: Neil Cavuto quite literally begging,
saying, I'm begging you supplicating Neil Cavuto
and he's on Fox News and they're ridiculing
the mask mandates. They're attacking the mask
mandates. They're talking about authoritarian.
All this crazy stuff. Neil Cavuto is right. We
don't have to agree with him on everything, but on
this issue, he is the most sensible voice on Fox
News now. Remember when Trump was president? Brian
Kilmeade was doing interviews with Trump. I just
reviewed one where they were both just talking
about how great the vaccines are. Everybody should
get them because at the time it was Wow, thank
you, President Trump for making the vaccine. Times
have changed, and now we're down to Neil Cavuto.
We'll have more coverage of this insanity on The
David Pakman Show Instagram. Find it at David
Pakman show on Instagram. We'll be right back.